I saw something earlier today in Twitter
that brought to mind some matters that
I'd wanted to do a Sadler's stories
narrating talking about having to do
with my mom and cooking
and a few other things as well and the
Twitter post was somebody who was
talking about cooking as a hobby for
them
and I remember reading it and almost
wanting to respond and you know thinking
oh wow cooking that's it is a hobby for
many people it sure isn't a hobby for me
even though I do a lot of cooking and
even some baking as well and other types
of food production and I have you know
really since I was a kid
you know it's there's a different sort
of attitude a different sort of mindset
for it to be a hobby something that you
could or couldn't do something that's
you might say it brings value to your
life but is essentially extra it's on
top of things
for me the way that I grew up cooking
was something that we experienced and
got involved with nearly every day and
of course we ate we enjoyed we devoured
the results of it as well and I I
suppose in some respects my childhood
could be said to have been rather
privileged in that we had this
opportunity when I say we I mean myself
and my sister both of us adopted into
the Sadler family and
we kind of got the best of both worlds
because both my dad and his family and
my mom and her family not only had a
vast
um repertoire of dishes and body of
knowledge about cooking and baking and
made it you know not necessarily in my
dad's case of daily practice but
certainly in my mom's case for much of
my childhood and a lot of people don't
grow up like that but I also grew up in
a neighborhood where people cooked as
well
and so
you know you take that sort of thing for
granted and had a massive formative
effect on me so I better start at the
start
um my mother's side of the family the
lemurizes you know they came out of uh
Chicago there's a whole long story there
that I won't go into my mom grew up on
50th and Halstead which was kind of a
poor neighborhood and they were working
class
um you know she eventually did go to
college although she dropped out to
marry my dad and you know most of the
family were trades people of of various
sorts or just workers and so it was just
taken for granted that you didn't eat a
lot at restaurants as a matter of fact
this is a bit of a digression but my
uncle aim used to complain as as did my
uncle John about the fact that when my
grandfather would drive them from
Chicago all the way up to Quebec to go
visit relatives because cheap occasions
you stay with family right they would
stop at a restaurant and my grandpa
would make them all decide to order the
same thing because he thought it would
be quicker he was the one sole driver
and so he wanted to get the hell back on
the road right away and you know of
course it doesn't make it go any quicker
the quick Cook's what they cook and
Uncle aim used to get upset about this
because you go to a restaurant you don't
eat what everyone else is eating unlike
every other day in the lemery's
household but you know
everybody you know either knew somebody
who cooked or cooked themselves because
that's how you you know saved money and
that's how you knew what your food was
like and so it was just kind of a an
expected thing in my mom's childhood and
this vast bunch of uh francophone people
living on that block
um many of them related to each other
all part of this vast La Marie's Clan my
dad grew up in a more privileged
situation in the suburb of Arlington
Heights and you know in part because his
dad who came from a family that was poor
as hell had worked his way up in
Corporate America he was at one time a
major consultant for the Glidden
Corporation then he retired and so he
had you know plenty of money married my
grandma uh and uh and then they had my
my dad
um and you know so they they lived a
kind of middle class to upper middle
class lifestyle and Grandma was a great
cook as a matter of fact
she was such a good cook that and she
was beloved by the lumry's family that
there were dishes that she would make
that my mom's family would actually
um beg her to make because she was she
was so good and she would make a
fruitcake at Christmas people joke about
fruit kicks her fruitcake was supposedly
like the best that anybody had had and
it wasn't like others I remember her
making these wonderful poppy seed cakes
and you know we would just always eat
well
and so that was in both of my parents
backgrounds my dad was a great Grill
cook you know he would cook steaks and
ribs and all sorts of other things like
that he worked very hard but on weekends
he would often cook for us and make us
pancakes and eggs and things like that
at breakfast and it was just sort of
taken for granted that hey if you want
to eat something cook it right or
somebody will cook it
because my dad while he was alive
working here in Milwaukee while we were
living way out in the sticks had a
really you know good job as a tax
attorney and as an accountant for a
while my mom didn't have to work
although she she did Moonlight a little
bit working at JC Penney's she could be
home much of the time in our house on
Glacier Pass and
she used a considerable portion of that
time to make just wonderful meals and
part of that was stuff that she'd
learned you know from her mom and from
my aunt uh Therese who we all called
Tony she she and Uncle Hubert were my
grandfathers brother and grandmother's
sister and they were sort of like the
grandpa and grandma or extra mom and dad
to everybody else in the family and Aunt
honey was just an amazing cook you know
there there were dishes that she made
for us that we lost the recipe to and
then found the recipe and thank God like
our Tootsie eye you know our meat pie
that we we have and so my mom learned
you know from some of the best you know
not fancy cooking but sort of like how
to do things at at home with whatever it
is that you have and everything was made
from scratch I mean there were occasions
where maybe somebody would buy a cake
mix or something like that but in
general
it was sort of a not no-brainer you knew
how to cook you had the ingredients it's
cheaper to cook from scratch you know
exactly what's going into it why
wouldn't you just do it that way so
that's what she did and she would make
just amazing meals day after day after
day and great desserts you know but it
wasn't that unusual in the neighborhood
that we grew up in I remember you know
next door to us were the scaffitos and
sometimes the grandma Mrs scaffido's mom
would stay with them and holy crap that
you know the the sauces she would make
with Italian sausage and pig's feet and
stuff like that
um you know all sorts of other people
would make other dishes and it was quite
common to share things back and forth to
have parties where there was lots of
great food you know my dad would grill
out on the deck when he had time and
make as I said ribs and steak and things
like that you know back then ribs were
actually quite cheap so they they knew
how to take things and I remember you
know some of my earliest memories of
living there are helping my mom out you
know peeling potatoes peeling carrots
cutting things off prepping she taught
us how to break down chickens and we
would also at at that time we would buy
an entire cow and store it in a freezer
in the basement and then we pull this
meat out and thaw it and cook it and do
all sorts of things and my mom
she thought to her credit she thought it
was really important that me and my
sister
not just learn how to cook some really
basic things but learn as much as we
could about how to make dishes properly
and that's what we in fact did it was
just sort of taken for granted that you
know you want to eat this sort of thing
learn how to make it and what a a gift
in retrospect she gave me by doing that
and it wasn't just her there was also
you know Grandma and Aunt honey Grandpa
would make oyster stew sort of a hair
Legacy of the family having lived out in
New England for a long time
um you know in the night well really
up until the 1930s when they all moved
to Chicago and
um
you just kind of pick these things up
you know she also taught me how to use
recipes but also how to modify recipes
what what to substitute how to think it
through and a lot of cooking is actually
that it's it seems like it's kind of a
mundane task you know doesn't require a
lot of brain power but actually being
able to figure out what's going into a
dish and what you can substitute and
what you can do and what you can add and
what you can take out that actually is
quite important
uh perhaps even more these days when a
lot of the foods that we eat you know we
talk about processed foods or Foods
coming out of boxes
um you know in the 1970s when I was a
kid
a lot of the stuff that was was
processed wasn't good for you but it
wasn't as bad for you as it is now and
you know as my ma after my dad died and
my mom had to go back to work a lot more
of the cooking fell on to my sister and
me you know my mom would do things like
batch cooking making a ton of chili
storing it out in the garage in the
winter and we'd go you know make the
macaroni and and uh grate the cheese and
go get the chili and heat it up and put
it all together to make chili mac or
pick whatever else you wanted my mom
used to make some pretty pretty awesome
spaghetti sauces as well and
um my mom never stopped making desserts
though she would make these amazing
mousses not just chocolate but
strawberry pineapple all sorts of other
things as well and if there was ever a
need for a cake she just kind of whip it
up and she taught us
how to not just how to do these things
but how to learn how to think these
these culinary matters through
and so you know I was actually
quite fortunate in that because when I
lived on my own I could
take care of myself I could go to the
store get everything I needed
you know menu plan for a week for two
weeks it was really handy when I wanted
to impress you know a date or potential
girlfriend or have a bunch of friends
over or go to a party you know I wound
up you know having sort of a
specialization in making Bavarian creams
and mooses and things like that and you
know when I lived on my own I could live
so cheaply because I could go to places
get everything that I needed if if
something happened to fall into my lap
you know somebody's like hey I've got a
bunch of zucchini you want it or here's
some Tomatoes or I would you know forage
around and pick blackberries or black
raspberries or you know I had a relative
who had a persimmon tree and I just I
could go on and on and on and on right
I could live pretty cheaply just by
cooking healthy tasty meals for myself
and whoever else I was involved with
um and that's you know that's that's
actually a really great thing I'm also
super fortunate in that I've got a wife
who similarly grew up in a house where
people cooked from scratch and who
actually worked for more than 10 years
at The Culinary Institute of America
where it's you know that's sort of the
Harvard of culinary schools the French
chefs and their kids there and so
there's lots of great lore and knowledge
and you know interesting fruit things
that that could be brought to the the
table as well but she and I both enjoy
doing fairly basic healthy tasty food
and we we do it all the time you know
just in the last couple days she roasted
a chicken she made a great soup I took
the chicken
I've got all the the meat off of it you
know made five quarts of stock from it
uh one of which will be used for a soup
that will have chicken and carrots and
onions and celery and cabbage in you
know later on this week I'm I'm going to
start making some more biscotti since
we're almost out of the biscotti that I
made and we could I could just go on and
on and on that is our day-to-day life
that's that's the way that we live we
cook things up for ourselves and we know
what's going into it
and we experiment we modify we Tinker
around sometimes because we we can think
our way not just taste our way or work
our way but think our way through the
food and for me
though the person who that is the the
you know most attributable to
is my mother but she had it because of
all these other people and I was
fortunate enough to have so many other
people just routinely involved in my
life
who do good cooking so for me it's not a
hobby cooking and baking
is kind of a an integral part of my life
it's something that helps me you know
when I'm cooking a particular dish to
have something to do with my hands
something I can bring to other people
and fill my own belly with but it also
connects me to these people that are in
most cases long gone my mom my grandma
Aunt honey my dad other people you know
who I learned recipes from here and
there or a technique from here and there
and over time of course I've learned a
lot more things have expanded my
repertoire of recipes
has
become quite extensive but I've all also
figured out what it is that I like and
it's not too complicated or too
expensive for me to put in the little
bit of time and work actually sometimes
not just a little bit of time but you
know time and work required to make good
food and to enjoy it particularly with
my wife and every once in a while with
other people as well so I think there's
a lot more I could say about cooking
Cuisine maybe I'll do that in other
Sadler's stories going forward but I
just wanted to
you know reflect on this a bit I've been
thinking a lot about my Mom lately and
you know the person she was and what she
gave me and my sister as we grew up with
her living out in you know the border of
Delafield and Wales on Glacier Pass and
then in Waukesha and then in other
places and I've really been
fortunate to have somebody who uh valued
food and cooking and the knowledge
that is involved with it and you know an
appreciation for all sorts of Cuisines
and an eagerness a hunger pun intended
for learning about this absolutely
Central aspect of human life so
that's the story for today probably tell
you some more stuff about other culinary
baking cooking eating things down the
line